[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend in
allen mit mir im Studio ist wieder Katja
streso später mit Fußball und Tennis
schönen guten Abend und wir gucken was
wir außerdem haben
Proteste gegen immer mehr geflüchtete
überlastete Kommunen Probleme bei der
Unterbringung SPD und FDP wollen neue
eu-asylregeln
söldnerchef pigrosche in wütet gegen
Russlands Militärführung und droht mit
dem Abzug seiner Truppen aus bachmut
sie sind bereit der Royale Puls steigt
London am Tag vor der Krönung von
Charles dem dritten
[Musik]
nächste Woche treffen sich bunt und
Länder um über einen Thema zu beraten
das schon sehr lange sehr hohe Wellen
schlägt es geht um die
Flüchtlingspolitik schon jetzt sprechen
sich SPD Innenministerin feza und
FDP-Chef Lindner für eine härtere
Gangart aus beispielsweise für
asyl-prüfungen bereits an den
EU-Außengrenzen dazu und was Zuzug von
geflüchteten aktuell für Kommunen und
Landkreise bedeutet Andrea Maurer
Schleusingen in Thüringen ein ehemaliges
Krankenhaus soll hierzu Asylunterkunft
werden für bis zu 100 Menschen seit
Wochen gibt es Proteste auch von rechts
der Bürgermeister versucht Ängste zu
nehmen es ist ja nicht so dass
Schleusingen noch keine geflüchteten
untergebracht hat wir haben ja ca
zwischen 40 und 50 aktuell schon die
aber privat und den städtischen
Wohnungen und wie auch immer in
einzelunterkünften eben da sind und da
merkt man gar nichts es ist eine
angespannte Situation angesichts
steigender Flüchtlingszahlen die den
Gemeinden nach Aussage der
bundesinnenministerin sehr viel
abverlangt wenn sie Feser fordert nun
auch einen verschärften Kurs in der
EU-Außenpolitik wie ihr Sprecher
erläutert worüber wir aktuell verhandeln
sind die sogenannten grenzverfahren an
den europäischen Außengrenzen bei den
Menschen mit einer sehr geringen
schutzquote also eine sehr geringen
Aussicht auf Schutz in der Europäischen
Union direkt an den EU Außengrenzen eher
also wir verfahren erhalten und
gegebenenfalls auch von dort
zurückgeführt werden können auch der FDP
Finanzminister verlangte stärkere
Begrenzung schließt einen Zaun auf
Nachfrage nicht aus das heißt
ich glaube das und Kontrolle
herzustellen auch der physische Schutz
der Außengrenze in Betracht gezogen
werden muss die Grünen sind klar
gegenabschottung sie fordern mehr Geld
für belastete Kommunen was allerdings
Kanzleramt in und Finanzministerium
ablehnen Uneinigkeit in der Ampel aus
Thüringen kommt ein Vorschlag wie das
Asylsystem bei gleichzeitigem
Fachkräftemangel zu entlasten wäre
derjenige der einer Asylantrag abgegeben
hat über Jahre hinweg lebt dem sollten
wir jetzt eine Gelegenheit geben dass er
sein Asylantrag zurücknimmt und dann
können wir in die Prüfung gehen ob wir
Ihnen nach Kriterien der
Arbeitsmigration eine dauerhafte
Bleibeperspektive ermöglichen können
rund 100.000 Menschen haben seit
Jahresbeginn erstmals einen Asylantrag
in Deutschland gestellt nächsten
Mittwoch treffen sich Bund und Länder im
Kanzleramt um über die
Flüchtlingssituation zu beraten
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck will der
deutschen
energieintensiven Industrie mit
Milliardenhilfen Entgegenkommen damit
sie international wettbewerbsfähig
bleibt Gegenwind kommt vor allem vom FDP
Finanzminister zurzeit Zahlen Großkunden
etwa Chemie oder Stahlunternehmen
ungefähr 13 Cent pro Kilowattstunde das
ist deutlich mehr als in den meisten
anderen Ländern deswegen jetzt die
geplanten Subventionen sie sollen den
Preis runter auf 6 Cent drücken und
damit die Unternehmen planen können bis
2030 laufen kosten würde das den Staat
bis zu 30 Milliarden Euro die anderen
zimmermann
aufatmen in der Papierbranche und
anderen energieintensiven Industrien ein
Vorschlag ist da um Industriestrom bis
2030 zu subventionieren dann sollen die
Unternehmen auf ausreichend günstigen
Ökostrom zugreifen können
auf die Frage woher die nötigen 30
Milliarden Euro dafür kommen sollen
antwortete die Sprecherin des
Wirtschaftsministers wir sehen hier
durchaus Möglichkeiten aus dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
natürlich gibt es da rechtlich hohe
Hürden aber und es bedarf dafür
Änderungen aber nach unserer Ansicht
sollte man das genau prüfen der 200
Milliarden Euro schwere Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds der für die
strompreisbremse eingerichtet aber nicht
ausgeschöpft wurde dürfte dafür nicht
genutzt werden so der Finanzminister und
seine Partei die die ganze Idee ablehnen
das ist ja gerade zu verrückt dass auf
der einen Seite gerade die
Kernkraftwerke vom Netz genommen worden
sind die sehr günstigen Strom geliefert
haben und auf der anderen Seite jetzt ja
der Wirtschaftsminister mit dem
Vorschlag um die Ecke kommt dass wir
zusätzlich Steuerzahlergeld in die Hand
nehmen um den hohen Strompreis zu senken
der Widerstand der der FDP hier entgegen
schlägt allerdings ist breit nicht nur
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgeber auch alle
anderen Parteien im Bundestag begrüßen
die Subvention die Kanzlerpartei hält
sie für unerlässlich
wir sehen augenblicklich das andere
Länder um uns herum auch genau zu diesem
Mittel des industriestrompreises greifen
die Amerikaner beispielsweise dazu noch
Zuschüsse zahlen und deswegen müssen wir
hier raus aus dem denken dass wir nur
dem Markt alles überlassen und
stabilisieren
Umweltverbände und Wirtschaftsforscher
kritisieren die Subvention halte die
nötige Transformation auf das Geld wäre
besser investiert in Digitalisierung und
Zukunftstechnologien
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist heute am
zweiten Tag seiner Afrika-Reise in Kenia
dem wichtigsten Wirtschaftspartner
Deutschlands in Ostafrika so Warp Scholz
für die Idee Fachkräfte nach Deutschland
zu holen bei Gesprächen mit Präsident
Ruto sagte er sehr in Kenia großes
Potenzial vor allem in der IT-Branche
weiteres Thema eine mögliche
Energiepartnerschaft etwa beim Export
von grünem Wasserstoff nach Deutschland
das dürfte den Kanzler auch
interessieren die Zufriedenheit mit
seiner Ampelkoalition ist weiter
gesunken auf ihr bisher niedrigsten
Stand auf 43% so das aktuelle ZDF
Politbarometer wenn am nächsten Sonntag
wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre könnte sich
die SPD mit 19% leicht verbessern die
cdu/csu würde sich mit 30% etwas
verschlechtern ebenso die Grünen mit 17
%. die FDP käme weiterhin auf 6 die AFD
auf 15 die Linke erreicht 5% bei einem
solchen Ergebnis hätte die
Ampelkoalition keine parlamentarische
Mehrheit
das komplette ZDF Politbarometer gibt es
heute Abend ab 22 Uhr im heute journal
und jetzt schon in der ZDF heute App
auch zur bevorstehenden
Bürgerschaftswahl am 14 mai in Bremen
gibt es aktuelle Politbarometer zahlen
und da sieht es nach einem Amtsbonus für
den Regierenden SPD-Bürgermeister
bovenschulter aus wie es um die anderen
Parteien steht und welche Themen in
Bremen wohl entscheidend sind dazu keine
nach den jüngsten Umfragen des
politbarometers hat vor allem Andreas
bovenschulte die SPD zurück in die Spur
gebracht sie liegt anders als 2019 bei
Umfragen wieder vor der CDU der populäre
Bürgermeister steht im Mittelpunkt der
spd-wahlkampagne
seit er kurz nach der Bürgerschaftswahl
2019 den Amtsinhaber ablöste hat Andreas
bovenschulte es geschafft sich bekannt
zu machen er kommt bei den Bremerinnen
und Bremern gut an so geht er mit einem
deutlichen Amtsbonus in die Wahl und hat
gute Chancen Bürgermeister zu bleiben
wenn am nächsten Sonntag
Bürgerschaftswahl wäre Kimi die CDU auf
27%, die SPD auf 30 die Grünen auf 13
und die Linke auf 9 %. die FDP könnte
demnach mit 6% wieder in den Landtag
einziehen die Bürger in Wut legen auf 9%
zu und während wieder in der Bremischen
Bürgerschaft einige Vertreter der
Rechtspopulist ischen Wählervereinigung
BÜRGER IN WUT gehörten vormals der AFD
an die Bürger in Wut können auf einen
deutlich besseres Ergebnis als bei der
letzten Wahl hoffen vor allem weil im
Namen der AFD zwei verschiedene
Kandidatenlisten eingereicht wurden und
sie deshalb nicht antreten darf
sPD Linke und Grüne haben im Wahlkampf
durchblicken lassen ihr Dreierbündnis
fortführen zu wollen die wichtigsten
Probleme sehen die Befragten in den
Themen Bildung Verkehr Kriminalität und
Klima bei den möglichen Koalitionen
schneidet ein Bündnis zwischen SPD und
CDU am besten ab diesen beiden wird bei
Wirtschaft
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung und Bildung auch
die größte Kompetenz zugesprochen
nach Vorwürfen der Vetternwirtschaft im
Wirtschaftsministerium von Robert Habeck
wird der Chefposten der bundeseigenen
Deutschen Energieagentur Dehner neu
ausgeschrieben hintergrund ist dass der
bisher vorgesehene Geschäftsführer der
Trauzeuge von Energie-
Offensive ukrainischer Streitkräfte
könnte nach Einschätzung von Analysten
unmittelbar bevorstehen Russland ordnete
heute die teilweise Evakuierung von
Gebieten in der Region saporisia an in
der sich Europas größtes Atomkraftwerk
befindet und in der schwer umkämpften
Stadt bachmut droht der Chef der
russischen Söldnertruppe Wagner mit
Rückzug wegen hoher Verluste und zu
wenig Munition Volker
es ist eine bizarre nächtliche
Inszenierung der Chef der russischen
Söldnertruppe Wagner prigoschin zeigt
auf die leblosen Körper seiner Soldaten
er sagt das sind die wagner-leute die
heute Nacht gestorben sind das Blut ist
frisch
bring goschins redest unterlegt mit
vielen Pieptönen wie zensiert er
beschimpft angebliche militärbürokraten
den russischen Generalstab den
Verteidigungsminister weil sie angeblich
zu wenig Munition liefern würden
in einem anderen Video kündigt in den
Rückzug seiner Söldnereinheiten zum 10
Mai aus der umkämpften Stadt bachmut an
einer Frau gegen Moskau den Putins
Regime hat die Stadt zum strategisch
wichtigen Knotenpunkt im Südosten der
Ukraine erklärt
macht schon lange Druck auf die
militärspitze bislang hat Putin ihn
immer unterstützt hat er diesmal den
Bogen überspannt
frigoschi halte ich nicht für verrückt
wenn er manchmal auch sehr merkwürdig
auftritt sondern ich glaube dass er
genau weiß was er macht und dass er auch
weiß wie er beispielsweise auf den
Generalstab und den verteilungsminister
in Russland Druck ausüben kann auch
heute wieder Bilder von brennenden
Raffinerien und Versorgungsleitungen im
Süden Russlands nicht weit von der
ukrainischen Grenze Experten glauben die
viel zitierte ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive rückt näher wir sind
sicherlich vorbereitende Maßnahmen für
die Offensive um den Nachschub und die
Versorgung für die russische
Streitkräfte zu unterbinden Zufall oder
auch eine bewusste Inszenierung am
Nachmittag veröffentlichte krämme diese
Bilder des viel gescheutenen
Verteidigungsministers Scheu er besucht
die Truppe nahe der Grenze zu Ukraine
und verspricht ausreichend Munition und
Waffen
wieder erschüttert eine amok-tat Serbien
nach dem Angriff auf eine Schule in
Belgrad mit neun Toten vorgestern hat
jetzt dann 21-jähriger südlich der
Hauptstadt acht Menschen erschossen und
rund 13 weitere verletzt offenbar nach
einem Streit hatte der Täter aus einem
fahrenden Auto heraus wahllos das Feuer
eröffnet ein Großaufgebot der Polizei
verfolgt den mutmaßlichen Schützen und
nahm ihn fest
Serbiens Präsident Vucic kündigte
schärfere Waffengesetze und strenge
Kontrollen an
seit Jahren ist für Verfassungsschützer
in Brandenburg Rechtsextremismus die
größte Herausforderung heute gegen die
Polizei im Süden des Bundeslandes in
Burg gegen eine rechtsextreme
Kleinpartei vor die an einer Schule
Flyer verteilte zuletzt bekam die
Thematik bundesweite Aufmerksamkeit nach
dem Lehrkräfte einen anonymisierten
Brief geschrieben es geht um Jugendliche
rechtsradikale die Lehrerschaft und
Mitschüler drangsalieren Nicola Albrecht
berichtet
offen posieren Schüler mit Hitlergruß
auf dem Sportplatz der Kleinstadt Burg
im Spreewald in ihrer Schule Hakenkreuze
an den Wänden Naziparolen auf
schuleipets rechtsextreme rassistische
und homophobesymbole in chatgruppen in
einem anonymen Brandbrief beschreiben
zwei Lehrer was an ihrer Schule den
Alltag bestimme Zitat tagtäglich sind
wir damit beschäftigt Schüler vor
psychischer und physischer rechter
Gewalt zu schützen wir treffen sie zum
Interview aus Angst wollen sie unerkannt
bleiben ich kritisiere an manchen
Kollegen dass sie nicht hinschauen dass
sie blind geworden sind auf dem rechten
Auge und das oftmals Rechte Taten als
jugendstreichen gestellt werden
angezeigt wurden die Vorfälle von der
Schulleitung erst nach der
Veröffentlichung des brandbriefs warum
so lange geschwiegen wurde beschäftigt
nur noch die Sicherheitsbehörden
davor gewarnt dass dort
Rechtsextremisten aktiv sind es jetzt in
diesem konkreten Fall schon dazu
gekommen ist das ein Brand ausgebrochen
Bekämpfung vor dem Prävention gehört
auch dazu weiterhin aber jetzt geht es
um Repression jetzt geht es halt auch
das Zurückdrängen von solchen Haltung
und Burg ist kein Einzelfall bestätigen
Beobachter wir haben da ein Problem und
das überall in Deutschland in
Brandenburg ist es jetzt ganz besonders
schlimm aber eigentlich muss jetzt mal
flächendeckend geguckt werden wo ist das
Problem und die ausgeprägt ist es der
designierte Bildungsminister
Brandenburgs kündigt Aufklärung und
Maßnahmen an ein Interview dazu gibt er
uns nicht unterdessen erreicht uns ein
zweiter Brandbrief diesmal von
Schülerinnen aus Burg wir haben Angst
schreiben Sie und dass sie in der
Minderheit sein nur kurz darauf werden
wir Zeugen wie Mitglieder einer
neonazistischen Kleinpartei Flugblätter
vor der Schule verteilen die Polizei
erteilt ihn einen Platzverweis und
verspricht bis auf weiteres vor Ort zu
sein
ganz anderes Thema jetzt morgen Mittag
ist es soweit Charles der dritte er wird
in der Westminster Abbey gekrönt und für
die Fahrt zurück in den Buckingham
Palace da steigt das Königspaar in
dieses riesige Gefährt the ghostate
krönungskutsche schon seit fast 200
Jahren acht Jahre werden sie ziehen aber
nur in Schrittgeschwindigkeit denn die
alte holzkutsche liegt vier Tonnen sie
quietscht und selbst die junge Queen hat
schon über eine furchtbar holprige Fahrt
geklagt und das nennt man dann wohl
Luxus Problem zu den letzten Royal
Vorbereitungen aus London Yassine
für all jene die nicht wie sie in einer
Kutsche unterwegs sein werden haben
König Charles und Königin Camilla für
morgen einen guten Rat
please mind ja es ist tatsächlich die
Stimme des Königs die hier vor der Lücke
zwischen Zug und Bahnsteigkante warnt
und einen Zug und u-bahnfahrern ein
fröhliches krönungswochenende wünscht
Charles und Camilla selbst waren heute
noch einmal in der Westminster Abbey zur
allerletzten Proben dort ist soweit
alles vorbereitet auch die Blumen sind
bereits am Platz 120 verschiedene Sorten
aus allen Teilen des Landes ein Symbol
für die große Naturverbundenheit des
Königs nicht weniger als spektakulär
soll es werden das krönungszeremoniell
offen gesagt es wird einem die Kinnlade
runterfallen die interessante Frage aber
wird sein ob der eine oder andere hinter
dem starken visuellen Eindruck die Kraft
der Tradition erkennen kann
doch die hohen Kosten von geschätzt 200
Millionen Euro sind Wasser auf die
Gefühlen der antimonarchisten sie wollen
morgen protestieren wir wollen
klarmachen dass dieses Land keine Nation
von Royalisten ist es gibt eine starke
Oppositionsbewegung gegen die Monarchie
nur neun Prozent sehen der Krönung mit
Freude entgegen
für die Königs treuen allerdings die
sich bereits an der Abby und dem Palast
eingefunden haben machten die Royals das
Warten heute schon lohnenswert rund um
die Krönung Charles des dritten werden
keine Mühen gescheut die britische
Monarchie noch einmal im allerbesten
Lichte darzustellen
morgen also Ausnahmezustand in London
Katja an Neapel hat das im Grunde schon
seit gestern Abend ja leider blieb es
nicht überall friedlich ein toter viele
Verletzte dass die unschöne Bilanz der
Feierlichkeiten nach dem Titel gewinnen
des SSC Neapel in der italienischen Liga
Neapel reichte gestern ein eins zu eins
bei Udinese Calcio gestern in Udine der
SSC Neapel zurück auf dem italienischen
fußballtruhen das lange warten hat ein
Ende Ekstase bei Anhängern Spielern bei
Trainers balletti 33 Jahre nach dem
letzten Meistertitel schafft eine Truppe
der Namenlosen die Überraschung in
italienischen Fußball zweiter Matchball
verwandelt Udine geht zwar in Führung
aber dann schlägt wieder er zu Viktor
und Siemens Wolfsburger top Torjäger der
Serie Abend mit seinem Ausgleich in der
52 Minute das reicht die
süditalienermeister 5 Spieltage vor
Saisonende zum dritten Mal in der
Vereinsgeschichte und während sie in
Udine den Platz stürmen erlebt Neapel
bereits den Ausnahmezustand Jubel
extraktase aber auch Chaos mehr als 200
verletzte und am Rande der
Feierlichkeiten sogar ein toter nach
Schießerei dies die ernüchternde Bilanz
des Abends Neapel erfolgreich und
chaotisch nicht nur der Titel erinnert
an die goldenen Zeiten mit Diego
Maradona
Tennisprofi Jan Lennart stroof war in
der Qualifikation für das ATP Masters in
Madrid schon ausgeschieden nach vielen
Absagen rutscht er aber doch noch ins
Hauptfeld und steht jetzt sensationell
im Halbfinale nach einem sieben zu sechs
fünf zu sieben und sechs zu drei gegen
den Griechen Stephanus zieht sie Pass
mit 33 Jahren ein bisherigen
Karrierehöhepunkt ein glücklicher Jan
Lennart Struff im ersten Satz Nerven
stark im Tie-Break gegen sie passt die
aktuelle Nummer 5 der Welt im
entscheidenden dritten dann das wichtige
Break zum 3:1 eine krachende Rückhand
des Mannes aus Warstein Stoff macht die
wichtigen Punkte zieht sie passt die
spektakulären daraus entwickelt sich ein
klasse Match
Stoff verwandelt schließlich dem
Matchball zum Sex zu drei als
Qualifikant gerade so ins Feld gerutscht
trifft er nun im Halbfinale auf den
Russen Aslan Kasse
und das Spiel soll in 41 Minuten beginnt
dann sage ich Danke Katja wir haben noch
Schiffsverkehr in Hamburg das ist
eigentlich nichts besonderes
außergewöhnlich ist aber was heute alles
auf der Elbe entlang schipperte er
würdige Großsegler seetüchtige
Museumsschiffe die prächtige
Einlaufparade eröffnet traditionell das
üppigste Hafenfest der Welt
HAFENGEBURTSTAG HAMBURG drei Tage
Spektakel am und auf dem Wasser
so turbulentes Wetter mit teils heftigen
Gewittern steht an zurzeit gilt noch
eine Unwetterwarnung für den Südwesten
Bayerns mehr dazu gleich von östentherly
die heute journalzeit an diesem
Freitagabend beginnt um 22 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka das gesamte heute 19
Team bedankt sich wünscht Ihnen einen
schönen Start ins Wochenende tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter heute war ja
einiges los mit Schauern und Gewittern
und das setzt sich auch weiter fort von
Westen her sehen Sie hier teilweise
Schauer und Gewitter es sind vor allem
hier diese violetten Farben das sind
meistens Gewitter die nach Osten ziehen
und vor allem im Süden da geht's auch in
der Nacht weiter und vor allem Richtung
Südosten gibt es auch noch teilweise
unwetterartige Entwicklung mit teilweise
40 Liter auf dem Quadratmeter Sturmböen
und Hagel mit zwei Zentimeter Korngröße
von Westen Herr lockert es auf und diese
Gewitter ziehen da auch dann auch ab
ansonsten der Regen der wandert nach
Nordosten Temperaturen dazu vier Grad an
der Ostsee und 12 Grad in Bayern und zu
morgen weiterhin Regen im Nordosten und
einem Tag Verlauf einzelne Schauer und
Gewitter im Westen überwiegend
freundlich aber hier kannst auch mal
Blitzen und Donnern bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 9 Grad in der Ostsee
und 24 Grad im Südwesten deutlich wärmer
schauen und Gewitter gibt es auch am
Sonntag teils Unwetter artig die ziehen
von Südwesten her auf höchste Werte bei
14 bis 23 Grad ein schöner Abend